Greg Sadler dr. Greg Sadler is a very
interesting philosopher first time I met
him he was working on faith and reason
Christian philosophy and Hildebrand and
some and anger and he's continued to
work on anger faith and reason and an
some very insightful will discuss almost
anything he it he's kind of like the
street evangelist of philosophers he he
he he does he does talks at local
libraries does talks at churches
basically he'll go talk anywhere and
he'll talk about anything is it it's a
it's it's it's it's a lot of fun he
started a company with his wife called
reason I oh if you want to click and
maybe help him out 600 videos he's done
on there he has two million views and
twenty thousand subscribers so that's
that's a pretty pretty big impact so
he's spreading the philosophical message
he he even does philosophical counseling
so if you need some counseling and done
he's even worked as some transgender
issues I think so and he also does
tutorial sessions in philosophy so the
the philosopher himself dr. Gregory
Salazar I present to you so Ron doesn't
mention that that we met at one of these
these stupid mill conferences years ago
and we clicked almost immediately back
then he was brother Ron hurl and we've
always had a great time talking it's not
entirely true that I'll go anywhere and
talk to anybody but it has to be within
some realm of competence because
otherwise I'll beg out but you know I'm
willing to go out on a limb quite often
so that maybe what's going on here this
is gonna be a bit different than many of
the other talks because I'm dealing with
something fairly specific the emotion of
anger
and then some of its implications for
leadership and organizations so there's
not so much big-picture stuff here and
set in the sense of metaphysics or
history or philosophy or things like
that but I think it's very useful and I
think that Thomas Aquinas provides us
one of the best models for understanding
anger what I'm going to do here in this
talk is there's there's seven parts but
I may not do all all seven part parts
the first three are more or less
theoretical just developing the model
and actually you don't necessarily have
to look at them now they're they're sort
of for reference
there's a lot of information in there
but I want to go through Aristotle's
theory of anger very briefly talk about
Thomas's treatment of anger as a passion
as an emotion and then look at Thomas's
discussions of anger and its relations
with rationality and morality and then
you know I want to do some application
since this is a leadership conference I
think that this is useful stuff for
talking about contemporary organizations
whether they're religious or
non-religious so I wanted to talk about
some common situations in which anger
becomes an issue and some of the
remedies that that Thomas proposes I
wanted to focus on this category of the
difficult good and what that might mean
in today's organizations to talk a
little bit about anger and its possible
uses and many abuses as a motivational
tool and then finish by talking about
leadership and leaders and anger so
let's start with the Aristotle Aristotle
in the ancient world is one of the first
theorists to seriously examine anger
it's not to say that he's you know the
first person to talk about if Plato of
course has this you know discussion
through most in the Republic and there's
a few other interesting discussions
elsewhere Plato talks about common
causes for people
with each other in the gorgeous and then
the Euthyphro but Aristotle is the
person who really brings it all together
he doesn't he never produces a work on
anger you know some of the way some of
the later ancients will do so we have to
piece together what he's what he's
saying to us from a number of different
texts and rhetoric book 2 is very
important for this the nikah McCann new
Demian ethics are important the politics
is important and there's a host of other
references here and there that are that
are important as well
he also has several different dimensions
of analysis of anger when Aristotle this
is in the topics he says when you talk
about anger you can examine it from the
perspective of the natural scientists
you know Susie coast or from the
perspective of the electricals you know
the person who's approaching it in a
more psychological way in my work on air
sublimator actually differentiates six
different modes of examination in his
works but here I just want to talk about
two of them primarily one is you know
the psychological dimension well how
does anger work how does it arise and
then he also has this sort of we can
call ethical or pro etic dimension to
anger as well and that's very important
and Thomas will take these up so in
rhetoric quote to Aristotle provides us
with a very coherent definition of anger
and it's got a number of different
moving parts a number of different
components anger is unlike some of the
other emotions and then it's very
complex it's already got feelings of
pain and desire mixed in with it's got a
the affective components it's got what
we might call cognitive components built
into it the sense that there's been some
sort of injustice committed very
important term in there by the way that
he uses is a phenomena you know which we
could translate as a parent that's how
it's usually translated but we can also
translate it as imaginary the people
will often imagine things that get them
angry and it's not just the cause
that's vitamin A it's also what anger
wants which is timreis translated
sometimes as revenge retaliation
retribution punishment it's going to
correspond to Thomas's use of vindictive
and a whole bunch of other than dict you
know - cognate s-- in his works Arizona
says that's my nominee - that the person
who's angry wants to see the other or
imagine the other person being hurt in
response being made to suffer in
response now the cause the main cause of
anger for Aristotle is what he called
slighted Olegario and
it takes three main forms and Thomas
will take these up we translate these
usually as contempt kind of Parnassus
spike Epidaurus lost and then however
you want to translate hubris you know
want an outrage insolence and eros level
doesn't do quite as much work parsing
these out as as Thomas does but he does
talk quite a bit about what how cut from
Asus works when we look at when we get
away from the effort or the the rhetoric
and we start looking at the APIs we
still start looking at certain passages
in the politics what we see is that
Aristotle views anger not only is a
psychological phenomena that's going to
happen in life wants to know how it's
going to happen he also wants to analyze
when anger is appropriate when anger is
the right thing when it's the wrong
thing what makes it the right thing and
within is you know theory of virtues and
vices there is a virtue that is
associated with anger private tastes
which interestingly enough you know in
in like the Greek New Testament
Flowers's is the meat right we translate
it in Aristotle scholarship as the mild
or the good temperate or something like
that when you're reading the Gospels you
think meat means never get angry at all
or something like that it's worth
keeping in mind though if you look at
the Septuagint and you look at the
description
of Moses as being this mild guy it's the
same term and we know you lost his
temper quite a few times getting in
trouble sometimes for that but being
right in getting angry quite a few times
as well so you know what sort of
virtuous disposition would this be
Aristotle gives us a number of sort of
qualifiers for this getting angry at the
right time for the right reason with the
right person we can turn these around
and think about you know the right
person great example how many of us have
been angry at one person and then in our
state of anger were irritable and easily
get angry at another person or have the
same thing happened to us that would be
a sign of not necessarily a vicious
disposition but certainly something
apart from virtue the virtuous person
it's not that they're never going to go
astray but most of the time they're
going to get angry when they should
they're gonna get angry to the degree
that they should they're going to
forgive when they want to forget
Aristotle says that the the mild person
is more disposed towards overlooking
these sorts of things - not interpreting
them in terms of you know personal
attacks or slights or things like that
now he also does discuss anywhere from
three to five vicious dispositions with
respect to excess Thomas takes him as
discussing three I think that the case
can be made this could be an interesting
sub for there being additional ones in
the nikah McCain and Damian ethics
discussions but three is probably enough
already you know he also says there's
one in deficiency if you don't get angry
when you ought to get angry and you do
that typically you're a vicious person
and if you don't get angry
on some occasions where you ought to get
angry you may not be vicious but you're
doing actions that are along the lines
of advice you're certainly not virtuous
by never getting angry so you know you
can see a big contrast between this and
not only you know a lot of Christian
ethics but also a lot of other ancient
ethics the Stoics for example said never
get angry it's always a bad idea you
read for example Senecas on anger
nothing good ever comes out of anger
Cicero who is usually willing to side
with Aristotle on a lot of things
against the Stoics takes the stoic side
and says anger is the worst you know so
there's that the epicurean see
themselves as being in-between the
resilience who are way too you know
bounds for glorifying anger and those
Stoics who are too puritanical Christian
you know thinkers come on the scene and
some of them have a zero-tolerance
attitude towards anger like John Cassian
casseon says that you should only get
angry at yourself for your vices that's
the only time you should ever get angry
and there's quite a few people like that
and they're you know they're working off
of scriptures that talked about anger
there's a whole interesting discussion
that could we can go into there you know
whoever gets angry with his brother some
versions actually inserted that without
clause and there's a lot of discussion
about that casseon says doesn't matter
you know forget that gloss Augustine
actually says well yeah without clause
that makes it that makes sense I'm still
not a great idea Aristotle is is
providing us with a robust conception of
anger in which anger can be the right
response but we also have to be on guard
a lot of the time against it it's also
directly connected with our conceptions
of justice and injustice so it's a
distinctively human emotion sumos is
felt by animals and animals can act in a
way that's like anger like or gay but
anger proper is really a human thing for
Aristotle it's also one of the most
rational of the passions so that's
something that's Hamas will it will take
up as well so you know you think about
this one of the key things to take from
this it's our very nature as beings that
are concerned with justice and injustice
and who are rational
that makes us more vulnerable to being
overtaken by anger so now when we turn
Thomas Thomas is gonna push can build
from Aristotle's account when it comes
to the discussions of the emotions he's
doing some really interesting
innovations that I think are quite
valuable but in many respects is
following Aristotle all the stuff that
I've got here is taken from the soma
because if you go to you know like the
commentary on the ethics you're not
gonna find anything in there that isn't
in love
the soma later on as far as anger goes
other things yes but now one of the key
differences is that Aristotle Thomas
interprets Aristotle as having you know
a domotic or irascible appetite or a
rexis however you want to translate
Aristotle doesn't actually say that but
you could read that back in and you
could say well look eros level does
divider axis into you know desire for
pleasure or avoidance of pain and then
this through most thing and then you
know places whatever that is and that's
hard to translate Thomas takes that as
being we'll all that aside Thomas is
sort of he's how do you wanted to do it
whether he's sort of you imaginatively
reconstructing what air assault should
have said or or reading something that
actually is there an Aristotle he says
that there's an irascible appetite and I
think that that's a really important
contribution there's a part of us that
is concerned with things beyond just
what the sensitive Orkin qu+ our
appetite wants or is concerned with
there's something that's distinctive to
that animals have that but not quite in
the same way that we do so he's
rethinking this and the irascible part
is concerned with the good and the bad
or the evil and more complex
the Koopa Super Bowl is it's the good or
evil considered in terms of some
difficulty difficult times or strength
elevate Sione fight
Magnum or arduous misuses rat Sione
artery pursuing or avoiding you know
involves running into these it's when
things get sticky that's when the inner
askable appetite gets engaged it is
shared in by by other animals they have
an anger response which seems to be more
focused on avoiding evil in prema pars
81 - he says by the irascible appetite
the animal does two important things
that are actually three it resists the
tacks that hinder what's suitable to it
it resists what inflicts harm upon it
and those are two different things it
also involves overcoming and rising
above obstacles and he when he's
thinking about why animals actually have
this why they have a second appetite
it's because they respected the special
inclination of nature to removing what
is harmful to changing their environment
to changing their interactions with
things so that you know the good can
actually be realized
anger is actually the most complex of
the emotions Thomas says it's not only
the the one emotion that doesn't have an
opposite which is an interesting thing
in itself but it's also the most complex
he says that it is a general emotion in
that it's an effect produced by the
concurrence of several causes so that it
embodies so we can think of it as
consolidating these these causes anger
he says already contains contrary within
itself because it has hope and sadness
mixed together
it also has pain and pleasure mixed
together and we can look at a number of
different aspects of Thomas's treatment
of anger we look at the emotions that
are involved besides just anger itself
what it's composed of anger involves
sadness as a response to some kind of
injury or some kind of threat it also
invited involves desire or hold and what
does that hope for for revenge
or I'm going to just call it vindication
because it's closer in in cognate it's
in the term that he is has been - Katzie
or
mindy cotta there's a whole bunch of
different cognate city uses he having
ideas that setting things right
that's what anger really wants and it
desires that it hopes for it the angers
also concerned with good and evil in
very complex ways they've used the the
injury or threat as an evil and it's an
evil because it's going to damage some
sort of good so there's this interplay
there if you use the other person as in
some respect evil because they're
threatening or or damaging generally by
interpreting what they do is malice it
also views the vindication opposed on
the other person as an evil that's
imposed on them but an evil that's
imposed on them as a good as the good of
justice so there's this very complex
interplay within the workings of anger
the aspect of difficulty is also
important to attend to he says
difficulty is presented by what
threatens are what injures there's
difficulty in preserving good or in
avoiding evil we become angry when
things are at stake when we feel that
they're they're threatened there's also
a difficulty involved in what it is that
anger wants which is that vindication
because generally people don't just let
us impose some sort of indication on
them that requires some some work as
well so anger is the emotion that
Prime's us to do these things that in
many respects need to be done that
sounds pretty good right at that point
so we should be angry all the time
protect ourselves and you know getting a
little bit more specific he takes up
Aristotle's sliding which he just sort
of transliterated as part of Atencio
and he distinguishes three modes so he
talks about contempt Aristotle called a
counter Parnassus Thomas calls it to
SPECT this sometimes
and that's treating a person in ways
that undervalue or devalue them
literally looking down upon right and
Thomas you know the Aristotle when he's
writing about this in in the rhetoric he
says some things that look like they
might not fit into his discussion of
slighting Thomas he has a way of
addressing these and saying no look it
always does end up being some sort of
slightest treating people in ways that
they they shouldn't be treated so
Aristotle say well when people interfere
with other people that you know that
makes them angry Thomas reads it into
what spikeless spite is interfering with
their impeding a person implementing
their will so he gives us a gloss on
something eros level doesn't explain to
us very well
insolence is is when you you treat
somebody else bad so that you can get
some good feelings from to think about
bullying for example all right that's a
prime case of insolence bully you so I
can feel like I'm the big guy and makes
you feel terrible and I delight in your
terrible feeling all of these get people
mad and all these not only good people
man for themselves they also get mad
when they see it happening to other
people and Thomas interestingly enough
will say that it's not just those who we
aren't friends with or those who we
identify with or even subject matters
that were concerned with like say
philosophy somebody makes fun of
philosophy you got a bad temper you get
mad at them for making fun of philosophy
he says that we can get angry on behalf
of another person in so far as they are
another another person as so far as
they're a member of the human race so
there's a wider scope for when we turn
to thinking about reason and morality
anger is concerned with justice and
that's the sort of Nexus for those two
she says that injury is injustice and
imposing vindication is justice anger
desires evil to the person not as evil
per se but insofar as it has some aspect
of the good or at least this is the way
it's
they they assess what they're doing as
just and as vindication so when I get
angry at you because you I don't know
you cut me off and then I go and I cut
you off even on you know doing something
stupid because it could cause an
accident right I think that I am setting
things right I think that this is a good
thing this is part of why we go so so
easily wrong with it now what determines
whether anger is going to be right or
wrong I mean tons of Thomas here what
determines whether any emotion is is
right or wrong what's the one thing that
we can say about all of them well
prudence and what does prudence do for
us in part right yeah if prudence allows
us to love proves a whole bunch of
things but prudence in this case is
allowing us to see what reason is
telling us what we want to do so not
every case of us getting angry is going
to be subject to reason much of it is
irrational
now the ear askable our axis or appetite
it can be a subject of virtue he says
insofar as it's moved by reason and when
that happens quite a bit then it can
have a perfecting habit that's what the
habit of gentleness or mildness or good
temper actually is going to amount to
for for Thomas so I want to talk a
little bit about three modes that this
takes one of which is not actually
virtuous vindication by its own impetus
you might say tends to produce a focus
in the person who's angry on you know
what they're doing is being right being
just tends to produce its own sense of
being rational or being reasonable
now even the reason I know what it's
trying to say their reason can actually
guide us and help us determine whether
the vindication that we're trying to see
just or not the reason he has to be
working in that case virtuous anger for
Thomas is going to be like what it is
for aerosol getting right getting angry
at the right time for the right reason
to the right extent letting it go at the
right time not transferring it to all
sorts of other people if we can
consolidate that into a habit we have we
have what we need we have a good
virtuous habit with respect to it he
also talks about zealous vindication
if you thought using the word zealous to
denote anger that's properly directed
and structured as he says in accordance
with the order of Reason and
interestingly this can even be motivated
by the virtue of charity he says that
when one seeks vindication not for one's
own sake you know but because the
neighbor or even God for offenses
against God or one's neighbor because
one's use those as one's own through
charity there's a you know we're talking
about zealous anger that's the way
Thomas makes sense of it now the
irascible Alexis can can obey both
reason and the will one way to do this
is to apply as he says certain Universal
considerations this can allow anger or
fear to be modified difficult to do once
you're actually angry of course right
we've all had people try to reason with
us or try to reason with ourselves when
were angry that doesn't work quite that
well but if we keep doing it we get we
get better at that he says also we
become angry at sometimes because reason
reveals to us that we've been injured
it's not just our senses that reveal
that to us sometimes reason says you
shouldn't put up with that this is a
place where you should take ask and so
like with the Aristotle we've got
somebody who is saying anger is quite
often a good thing and the right thing
for us to do now there's there's many
other cases where we're not supposed to
get angry right so I'm going to go into
those now he says anger can interfere
with or cloud over or even seduce reason
into its service and this occurs he says
in
because reason because anger cyllage
eise's he's taking this from the era so
he doesn't mean cyllage izing in the
sense of like the formal syllogism you
know with with you know you know three
three propositions and all that's right
what he means is it puts together lines
of reasoning anger is a rational early
some irrational emotion so anger can not
only involve reasoning it can also
impedance he says when when reason is
leading anger is really a good thing
when anger is leaving then reason ends
up getting sort of corralled in to its
service and then we get into all sorts
of trouble now he says we can talk about
three vicious dispositions and sort of
types as ways of going
characteristically wrong again here's
the place where anywhere Aquinas is very
closely following Aristotle but making
some great contributions of his own he
talks about wrath ill will and rancor
wrath is the people who get angry
quickly and more angry than they want
these are the hothouse Aristotle says
these people aren't that bad because
they also tend to quit being angry
fairly quickly alright this is where
Aristotle that will distinguish between
the hotheads who do that and then the
people who are just a askable that's a
different advice thomas lumps them in so
these are people who get more angry than
they should with the wrong people that
sort of thing then there's even worse
than that though there's the bitter the
people who hold on to anger who brew who
even conceal their anger there's a
really interesting remark too by the way
in prima Secunda 42:5 where he says that
we really ought it he's saying about
fear he's saying we should fear the meek
and the cunning why because they tend to
conceal their anger we should fear that
more than regular people because he's
talking about this this sort of tendency
what do we call this passive
aggressiveness sometimes where the
people would be wait so they can they
can stick to you you know but they're
angry and then with the rancor these are
the people that are that are different
they they won't rest until they exact
some sort of punishment Aristotle calls
them the hollow posts I like to
translate that sometimes as the pains
and the assets the people who are just
you know irritating all the time they
they always gotta they gotta be right
you know they got to have things their
way that that's a vise that's a
characteristic condition of a human
being right now
anger is one of the capital vices as
well
Thomas inherits this this discussion of
the eight capital vices which then
become seven deadly sins and he you know
endorses it takes it on anger is one of
them
how does anger you know lead to that it
tends to produce other vices and sins
and you can see some discussions of that
on the handout she's said something
really interesting at one point he says
when we act from a vicious habit there's
malice rather than just ignorance or
passion involved why because a kind of
unnatural reality is generated the
person comes to see acting that way as
suitable for them as involving goods for
them so that you know the greedy person
tends to see the world in a greedy way
right the angry person tends to start
you know that only thing that the person
who's got you know hammer sees every
problem is a nail they every person ten
starts to see everything in terms of
justice and who's being wrong and how I
should get you know revenge or you know
vindication that tends to become their
mindset a lot of angry people actually
generate the very conditions in which
they get angry and we've seen this
happen quite often now what can help us
with that there's two virtues that that
Thomas talks about in particular the
irascible appetite is such really falls
under fortitude because because
fortitude is supposed to structure that
that keeps us from that keeps us from
from you know withdrawing from reasons
dick
under the influence of those irascible
emotions but the one that that he talks
about in terms of the virtue of mildness
is temperance mildness restrains the
desire for the indication it tempers it
in a certain way if we want to be very
funny so that's that's not everything
that you could say about about Thomas's
theory of anger but that's already quite
a bit of time consumed let's talk now
about some some you know present day
stuff if we think about slight you know
can we identify these three types of
sliding in interpersonal relations and
in organizations that people treat each
other in contemptuous ways that people
impede each others will do people
sometimes inflict you know pain or
suffering on other people just because
they get a kick out I think we can say
yes those are great people becoming
angry and anger within organizations is
something that can cause an awful lot of
friction there there's also a tendency
for anger in one person to spill over
into other people if I get angry so I
get angry at Ron because Ron says
something you know mean to me and I've
got a bad disposition with respect to
anger and now you know you're my
customer and I treat you badly and now
you're ticked off at me and now you're
going to talk to my manager pretty soon
we're all aim we want to be a template
to how these these things these things
happen there's also personality
conflicts miscommunications you know
salt'll had the example and thomas has
this example somewhere about a person
not being as interested in a topic as
the person who's you know really
fascinated with it is people get angry
over that sort of thing we want other
people to see things as important as we
do and if you're the customer and you
want me to care about your order and I
don't care about your order you're
you're probably going to feel that I'm
I'm sliding you and so you're going to
get angry another thing that's very
important in Oregon is
as I think is the sacrifice of working
towards justice to you know to other
values sacrifice and justice for other
concerns and three things that I applaud
and this might be something we're a lot
of people would have even better it is
the bottom line there's a constant
tendency to sacrifice the legitimate
interests of employees of you know
managers customers all sorts of
stakeholders to some sort of bottom line
and if that happens people are going to
legitimately get angry you should expect
that to happen
another thing would be the keeping up
appearances you know academic
institutions I think are particularly
susceptible to this but but companies
that are very worried about their brands
sometimes - or you know the good of the
company there's a rather vague way that
can generate quite a bit of anger
failure to address issues that typically
cause or prolong anger within
organizations you know when people don't
feel like they're being listened to when
they're being treated as merely being
irrational for being right so if you get
angry at you lose
alright usually when you're dealing with
HR okay I'll blaze through as much as I
can then I think that that's a bad
paradigm to work with I think that in a
lot of organization so I'm gonna give
you this great big broad a lot of
organizations everything dealing with
anger has been outsourced to HR that's
not where we want to have it in part
because you know this is something that
it's going to be happening everywhere
and leadership needs to be involved in
it leadership needs to be modeling you
know good attitudes towards anger and
helping people work through things but
also in part because the HR people
aren't themselves equipped to deal with
them they've got these these
psychological models in place or you
know communication techniques or things
like that you can buy all sorts of
packages for these and most of them
stress you know when you know when
angers happened something bad has gone
on right and maybe she talked it out but
they don't actually try to get it when
anger is legitimate and how you might
deal with the fact that people do have
to impose vindication upon each other
the we are we want to be asking
ourselves questions like well to what
degree should we let people say hey you
know I don't like what you're doing
there you're a jerk you know that can be
vindication in some cases that can get
you in trouble with HR saying stuff like
that in some places so I think that
Thomas knew the black Simon say I think
that Thomas offers us a lot of resources
for understanding anger in a variable
cost nuanced way that would let if we
can get this into organizations can let
us handle the problems that are that are
arising and that are going keep on
rising so long as we remain human beings
so
yeah go back to me okay Paris meeting
system corresponding virtue correct yeah
but you're saying that list is not to
ramp on their Studios one of the seven
deadly sins right angered by itself is
not angered by its offensive passion is
not yet anger as a capital vice or a
very deadly sin you have to have a
vicious disposition for that and so that
the virtuous disposition of mild mustard
weakness or how we live parse it out
there's a lot of translations for that
that would be once what's opposed to
that would be what keeps definitely
happening but for Thomas like I put it
up that does sort of like gets sucked
into waking up its Earth's mass mad
prudence way the virtue
ten minutes sorry so yeah whenever
Thomas there's this very complex in
tribulation of these but yeah within the
scheme of the seven deadly sins there's
a lot and you know opposed virtues
yeah they're fun very interesting I did
teach about anger using it as an example
in in ethics classes when we talk about
Aristotle but then I also did an Indiana
state prison the prisoners organized
their own continuing education program
there there's a whole conversation that
could be had about that there was a
culture of education at Indiana State
Prison that no longer exists there that
was incredibly transformative in you
know changing changing these guys it was
it was not just working upon them and
subjects they were using what was being
brought to them to change themselves to
their own discussions and so they
organized a summer continuing education
thing because there was nothing like
that in the summit so one summer I did a
class on the virtues and we looked at
Aristotle on anger and they used some
similar handouts and some of the guys
found it extremely useful because
there's so many of these things where
and this is might be something that I
think some of some of the audience would
be better at articulating than I am
there's something about understanding
the way the emotions work that gives us
a power over them that isn't a new agey
kind of thing you know or a self-help
kind of thing there's there's an
intelligibility there that allows us to
then figure out where we are and how
screwed up we are and start unscrewing
ourselves up this is important in
spiritual information
yeah yeah which principals yeah that's
yeah yeah hence your cut yeah don't even
if you have the wrong faculty psychology
that's that's where the Stoics went
wrong because this for the statics all
you have is you know the pro erases the
Faculty of choice which is in the
rational faculty and then you have the
emotions but they're really just modes
of thought and and they're totally
irrational you know so the wrong kind of
faculty psychology is not going to any
anger and hope and fear and even despair
these these are all irascible emotions
are ways of our making sense of the good
that we desire the evil that we want to
avoid and the situation that we're at so
they connect us with reality but they
can also they can also give us
yeah yeah I mean they can also lead us
into thinking reality is very different
than than it is like the coward who was
afraid of everything
yeah well vengeance is vindictive and
that's that's what anger desires and I
talked about that in terms of zeal and
yeah looked at that stuff
bi didn't talk about the mercy part here
in part because it's denied at the time
but into the paper I'm supposed to be
writing a paper for this and the paper
just kept getting bigger and bigger and
bigger like they do so it'll be in
notice too that when you impose
punishment on a person they're generally
think that you're doing wrong and
punishing them because otherwise they
wouldn't be doing what they were doing
the first place and so then they're
gonna get angry at you so when you know
if you're a boss you're trying to you
know moderate your own anger and figure
out how much you ought to punish in this
case because the punishments actually
deserved you also have to think about
how that person's anger is going to
affect things even if there's totally a
key guard please she was murdered by
normals and mostly yeah in the state
room yeah and go back to the start
institution
and came back yeah
what happened people who are in I can
attest that from personal experience
that when you have anger problems I got
interested in this go ahead pretty
serious anger problems and can't say I'm
virtuous with respect to anger yet it
does you look for opportunities in ways
to intervene you know you're more prone
to that there is very real training also
about the connection between anger is an
emotion and then the through most more
broadly speaking you know and this is
why Plato your treatment saw that as a
necessary component to actually get
things done reason by itself it's great
because it tells us what to do but the
appetites won't actually be governed
without you know something coming down
yeah
oh yeah finding the truth if I have done
for the moment office to finish like my
carnival for 35 and somebody cuts me off
the tractor beyond school right away I
want to speed the car out of them
there's no kind of Jefferson as well
like justice and some helpers remain
that that breaks through the city of the
great long lecture us intellectually
I'm going to say one thing about your
question
we know I'm going to get angry at other
people you know towards whom they can
have relations of Justice Thomas
considers this when he's talking about
you know anger and its relation of
justice we getting angry at inanimate
things that aren't persons this is a
sign of how screwed up we are you know I
can remember being a kid and getting
angry at the wind for blowing in my face
you know and you know the last talks
about that John Cassian he says that
these marks go out to the desert because
they you know like the retreat they
think they're going to get away from it
all you bring your anger with you and if
you're not angry at your friends back
there you're gonna get angry at your
book at your pen at your sleeping mat
you're talking about this in the
instances and it's so irrational yeah
well the first thing is people are
without resources you know or the
resources that are readily offered to
them don't turn out to actually be
resources at all and then with respect
to anger a lot of the anger management
stuff that's available will actually
it'll wean people away from really bad
vices it'll make them vicious in other
ways you know like for example I'm
actually not an opposite I'm not an
opposition to cognitive behavior therapy
or stuff like that
I think some of that is quite good but
you see them very often saying you
shouldn't focus on whether anger is
right or wrong just you know it's always
a bad thing to get angry not not all of
them but much of the literature out
there and so ok so if you if you take
that position and that may be what's
offered to you right there's not nobody
else on the scene then you end up
developing a different voice and you
either become cast as aggressive or
you're not angry when you should be so
what this sort of stuff can do
offer us more sophisticated models that
do more justice to our human nature
which is complex you know and then allow
us when I was talking to about the
prisoners you know when a prisoner
engages in moral Reformation what what
happens is they're working upon
themselves there has to be a choice made
to sort of take agency and say this part
of me is really screwed up I'm gonna
work on this and I don't want this to be
me forever it can't just be something
imposed from the outside but people can
only do that if you actually have
resources to offer them you know and so
that's what I think that this is really
great about ancient philosophy medieval
philosophy yeah especially other
so anger as anger is what I would say is
more something felt by humans who are
normal you know Thomas talks about the
difference between anger and hatred
which is you know Aristotle does this
too and so does Augustine Aristotle says
anger is felt for specific reasons the
angry person wants the other person to
suffer in return the person who hates
wants the other person literally not to
exist and you can be so you can be
driven by by different passions other
than just just anger we narrow our set
of facts about people who are whether we
translate as bcl a brutal like they do
there's nothing you can do with them
anymore I think that's what's I cop a
psychopath II or associate sociopathy
really amounts to it's part of why we
can't do it
strictly speaking but we can get it when
we need them crazier
yeah another thing I was going to say
through that so I forgot about that fool
me I was bringing it up you
Aristotle points this out and then
Thomas picks this up we did we get
angrier with those who we think wronged
us out of malice you know in Arizona
it's it's it's out of injustice in
Thomas it's it's out of balance as
opposed to those who are doing it on
passion or are doing it out of some sort
of mistake or air or this chance and
part of like giving yourself on track
with anger is learning how not to see
what other people are doing to you
because they're gonna do stuff people
are gonna bump into you and the angry
the person who's got a vicious
disposition with respect to anger they
see everything as it as an instance of
malice and the same thing could be said
about like inanimate objects if I'm
seeing my book as malicious because it
fell with the pages open there's
something I'm really badly off if I can
just see that as a missed chance you
know I too came on and Aaron sounds
great then I can say oh it's not that
big of a deal I still feel like
irritated but the the irritation will go
away you know
yeah
yeah yeah sometimes when you talk things
through you find out like there's laters
like I'm angry at this and then I
realize that really angry at this and
then three years later I was really
angry at this you know what time it says
something like that you know all the
irascible emotions are secondary in that
sense they they're all trying to realize
the difficult good in one way or another
and we only feel them in Parkers we have
other emotions already in play with
angry's it's really clear because anger
has sadness involved it has desire
involved hope sometimes even joy like
when they become addicted to the thought
of revenge yours dwelling on it and
stuff like that people people get really
joyful yeah what happens or however you
want to translate it you know
yeah and inflicting regatta juice you
know one of the one of the great quotes
that Aristotle used came from the Iliad
anger sweeter than honey dripping from
the tongue sweeter than honey dripping
from the comb yeah
so Thomas like Aristotle recognizes that
there is a somatic you know component to
this what's over there so Aristotle says
for example that once a person becomes
angry their body is in motion he thought
it would like blood boiling around the
heart which Thomas used to but we don't
need to be wedded to that to say once a
person gets angry there's these changes
going on in their body that make it
easier for that anger to continue so
Aristotle recognizes that Thomas
recognizes that that can make it more
difficult to deal with it
some people are temperamentally Thomas
thinks more prone to irritability you
know again we have much better medicine
and scientific explanations of that than
them heated like that we know that if I
drink 20 cups of the seventh day I'm
probably not going to be good company
although Thomas could figure that out
too but so there is there's a physical
level they all reduce they all avoid
reducing the the ethical and the
psychological just to the physical which
is what I think a lot of people today
don't do I think a lot of people want to
stay well neuroscience is going to give
us all the answers about this
you look at a lot of the experiments
that are carried out in the name of
neuroscience and the the groups that
have worked on a very small the
conclusions that are drawn a very large
they're always done in in circumstances
that are rather artificial you know I
don't put much of much faith in that
approach myself yeah
yeah pushing you know one of the things
that does work from anger management is
this technique of like just going and
taking a walk right but it only works if
you don't remind yourself that you're
taking a walk because you're angry
because if you think about the anger and
all exactly some people talk about
apathy
yeah I know from other from you as a
father
yeah it's it's been useful yeah yeah
you know another thing another thing
with that tune I'm saying this from from
some personal experience is for many
kids the the models that they're being
given deprived them of hope of of change
and so you know if you if you understand
anger and why you're angry and you
actually have something that says look
you it could get better then you're not
going to despair which can generate more
anger as well yeah but a lot of kids you
know will say things like I I hope I
don't get angry because I don't know
what I'm going to do afterwards and once
I get angry I can't do anything about it
and they're saying that because people
are telling those things
yeah yeah then that replicates something
that the Stoics actually found useful in
dealing with anger which is to have what
they call dog nuts at hand you know
short passages about the nature of
things and they were I will be lemony
like discussion about how effective this
was then the anger is either side it's
get straight as you know I mean people
can have all sorts of Thomasson an
aerosol both talked in very reasonable
ways about like people realizing that
they won't be able to get revenge so
then they'll quit being angry and you
know our experience shows us that people
can have all sorts of crazy miss
estimations of their possibility of
getting revenge so my like you know I
don't know writing something on YouTube
about some celebrity I'm getting revenge
on them you know so long that's it final
many aspects you know so long as I can
somehow think that it's revenge I can
get suckered in by it yeah so
you do love Scripture scholarship
talk about the biblical understanding of
justice yeah right relationship if we
desire justice in anger and we really
are seeking punishment what is the
nature of that punishment the true
nature though we tend to overdo it
yeah but is it somehow seeking right
relationship with that person and so in
some way seeking their reform would
satisfy our revenge
and so correcting someone is actually
and saying look this hurt me I would not
like to do it again yeah I think it was
wrong but is that enough punishment just
saying that to somebody and it hoping
that that has an effect of their
Reformation but dependent somebody I
mean some people you can't reach without
you know imposing pretty high penalties
on them the Thomas let's talk about this
the can mean no I mean that's their
desire no it can't be what with with the
desire is is for imposing vindication
now that vindication could be for their
reform was that the true desires with
equality
yeah
so that's what I think they are
integrated when a person's virtuous and
and partly challenges to to be able to
integrate them because we could like pay
attention to one and not to the other
end
Yeah right and that's where that's what
he talks about it right that's that's
where he talks about what Ron was asking
about which is the motive of vengeance
yeah oh yeah they had it coming you know
they had it coming
you know yeah I mean it's like I mean
that's one of the paradigmatic instances
that cushion really cushioned
discussions about anger tend to focus on
you know there's that there's these
passages like in the Sermon on the Mount
you know Thomas does think that there
are cases where we want to get angry
where it's the right thing to do
presumably you know this this you know
god man is going to be you know okay
with his psychic makeup however we want
to put it you know but this isn't that
with respect to the fig tree oh yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so that's another thing too that
when one sec there is something that's
worth bringing up Aristotle talks about
the possibility of having a virtuous
disposition with respect to anger where
you don't actually feel the anger but
you act as reason what bid an angry
person to act in those circumstances the
Stoics also treat that so it could have
been that Jesus is you know just just
this house store it would interpret
Jesus and that he was saying I'm not
really angry but I'm gonna like make the
face
yeah I have to see through that I don't
think that the prisoners were unusual
for our culture
oh you mean like which vicious
disposition well I mean I think
calcium's right about this Kassem thinks
the only time we should get angry at
ourselves or get angry at ourselves for
our sins and stuff like that I'm not
going to say that he's right about that
part but we should they actually get
angry at ourselves when we screw up you
know not not in the sense that we begin
to hate ourselves and act in irrational
ways to ourselves but we should get
angry at the things that screw us up
where else should we get angry I mean
you know when we see mismanagement of
relationships or offices or stuff like
that it's legitimate to get angry but
then it has to be acted on in the right
way you know I've run into so many
people that would get angry about
something like their the parish priest
is doing and my first response is did
you talk to the bishop no and you
realize they just like to get angry that
stuff even sometimes legitimate stuff
but anger can be a great catalyst for
getting things done that need to get
done you know yeah
most to you
yeah it's true so the stealing alright
so that's part of what Thomas is tacking
that is the difficult good you know
there's there's there's opposition to it
but some of it is I mean sometimes we
get angry because people just jerks to
us and we do we love doing anything or
intending anything and they come along
and they just act like you know jerk
stress for no reason us at Hoover says
you know yeah
you see legitimate cases yeah we're
always in situations where everything's
piled up on top of everything else it's
alright we get to work on this just this
this virtue in isolation from everything
else we live in environments that are
very messy you know when you're asking
about that in the mind and they're
minded about Martin Luther King wrote a
book towards the end of his life called
where do we go from here and he was this
is after he became unpopular because the
Black Power movement had sort of
supplanted stuff and he was he was
saying look if this is all you've got
two offers counter violence and rage
that's not going to that's not going to
solve anything
now is that the answer for today yeah
but you know probably not I don't know
you know but the other thing that I'm
reminded of fear and I was going to talk
about here later when you're trying to
adjudicate who should be angry and who
shouldn't be angry you're placed in
situations where it's always been be
messy and you try to work out the best
understanding of it as you can
Alistair McIntyre is is really
interesting piece about moral dilemmas
where he says moral dilemmas genuinely
exist
they exist precisely as a sign of how
screwed up things of God there aren't
more dilemmas in the abstract you know
there's there's more dilemmas when we
are in cases where we do have to choose
between x and y and neither one is is
optimal because we didn't choose Z back
then and I think this situation is like
a you know to the nth power example of
that yeah yeah
culturally the past is visit passport
that aristocrats weird the Western mind
is really kind of guilty but the native
culture yesterday and what we're really
talking about identifying something more
than personal anger but when you would
identify as a generational it's
something that is is in cultural not
just consciously but I kind of
subconscious also thing and I don't have
an answer for that you know we do a lot
of forgiveness forgiveness meditations
after they identified
that kind of knowledge and you get a gut
lining for Johnson but but also what
what we do I did this about again
we're dealing with Iran and I began to
say who is this Indian drum I didn't
realize the injustice yeah committed
against Iran and Triton was a tortured
mistreated he was kind of you know when
he lost all his dignity
crying continues well this is awesome
place or something I think you ever ask
a few things to say once we start asking
about these like really big generational
civil civilization level things we're
beyond the level of analysis that the
Tomas would provide us with maybe we can
stretch it I don't know that's source as
far as this goes uncharted territory I'm
not a you know specialist in in Middle
East politics or history of stuff with
that but I do follow some of this stuff
and I would say that to begin with
within the Islamic world we have a lot
of not a heterogeneity of groups you
know so it's difficult to generalize
about you know Islam as as such because
yeah you have the Sunni Shiite division
of them you know are you talking about
you know which Shiites are you talking
about and then there's all these other
things that are layered on top of that
tribal affiliation the nationalities
that we imposed you know on people and
stuff like that and then there's this
this history I think you can't say this
if we're talking about what people call
radical Islam there's there's a you know
sort of long long felt historical
grievance involved with that we're gonna
call Salafism whatever that you you know
you have this first reaction to the myth
to the the Mongols coming in and raising
hell all across you know the entirety of
Iraq and destroying lots of drainage
ditches and turning areas that were you
know you know previously pretty verdant
into the deserts and a theology
beginning to emerge about that God is
God is
angry with us because we've abandoned
the the proper ways then you know that
gets used by Wahhabi
in figuring out why Islam has lost out
to the west and then that gets taken up
by 20th century figures like cut up and
brought into that I will say this too
that when I'm looking at those phenomena
and radical Islam I actually one of the
areas that I work in Rhonda's know about
this is fascist studies and yeah I mean
you know it's just a sort of a sideline
because I have an interest in that
historical phenomenon and you can look
at you know radical regimes like that
and then you know there's a debate about
whether we should talk about you know
Islam of fascism or stuff like that and
I think no that's a different type of
totally totalitarian approach that makes
20th century fascism and even twentieth
century you know marches lemon ISM look
pretty pale in comparison because it can
draw upon this incredible historical
reservoir of stuff going back to the
time of Muhammad for its ideology now
you you punch in all sorts of rage among
primarily among young men at the treated
you know poorly by the government's who
often don't serve anybody's interests
except for the powerful not even ours
and we sometimes install them and they
don't they'll do what we want them to do
and and you've got you know recipe
you've got a ideology that could just
suck them in and and that's why things
like Isis can actually you know you look
at what's going on with that they can
find recruits and then the recruiting is
coming alive part fueled by by anger I
think but they're getting stood still
we're here we're getting way beyond
Thomas's analyses I'm not sure how
they'd apply those to that that's -
that's sort of my two cents take but I'm
again I'm not
that's interesting
each other
that's untrusting another interactive
that also could apply to organizations
when people are like checked out you
know that's probably bad sign so yes
sure yeah the spirit for leadership
as long as overcoming if when
complaining overcomes complaining is the
key antidote to overcoming criticism
contempt stonewalling
if you do that then you break the back
it's a form of winter when people get to
complain amber actually listen to the
other person and you live in the culture
yeah well we have the other speaker
okay well you guys have given me a lot
of good stuff to think about too so
that's right